Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello!
Okay, welcome!
This is going to be my very first time playing Ark ever.
And like, honestly, I actually don't know how the ping is going to be like.
Because Hiro was like, you might need to get something to help you boost your ping to the server, maybe.
And I was like, oh, it'll be fine.
We'll figure this out live.
I should have, I might have, should have, you know, tested it out.
Tested out the server ping before, you know, before the stream.
But like, I don't know, I just believed.
If I believe enough, it'll be okay.
As long as we keep believing, it will be okay.
Yes, yes, welcome.
I've never played Ark before, guys.
Never in my life.
The reason why this we're playing Ark...
Very late at night is because this is the Bilibili VTuber server that Hiro invited me to.
And, you know, a majority of the people will be playing, you know, at their hours.
Not... because I was asking Hiro, I was like, oh, like, what time do usually people get on?
And they're like, she was like, oh, like, 4 a.m.
my time.
So I was like, maybe I should play.
Maybe not.
I'm just thinking, I'm gonna...
This is a compromise.
Like, you know, maybe not 4 a.m.
I don't really wanna... I don't really wanna play Ark at 4 in the morning.
So 11 p.m.
would be the best bet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Now placing bets on how she's going to pronounce Wyvern.
Wyvern.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yes, I have zero knowledge of this game.
Um...
And, uh...
And...
I've never played Ark before, so this is gonna be interesting.
I'm ready for all the backseaters to, like, yell at me because I have no clue what the fuck to do in Ark.
I have zero idea what to do.
Um...
And...
Oh yeah, also a little funny update.
So, like, you know how, like, yesterday I was like, you know what?
Let's just play every copy...
Like, let's just play copyright songs yesterday.
Well, not a cop...
Okay, not technically...
Yes, like jazz.
Like, I mean, it's still jazz.
It's not like clicking...
Uh...
It's not like Disney composed a jazz song.
It was like a cover song of jazz.
But anyway...
I got...
I'm sharing revenue with Disney, Nintendo, and Ghibli.
Look!
If I was gonna get copyright strike...
If I was gonna get, like, copyright strike...
I want all the companies fight each other for my five dollars.
Like, I don't want one single company have that entire five dollars.
I want all of those companies fight for it.
So, like, in the end...
You know...
They all get, like, 50 cents a month.
And I'm gonna have to answer some shit.
Like, I don't care.
Now all three of them will have to share.
Fight, fight, fight, fight.
That's what I said.
That's what I was like.
Look, if I'm gonna be playing, like, jazz songs from...
If I'm gonna get striked...
I might as well just commit.
You know?
I might as well fully commit.
And just play all the jazz music.
From all the companies.
Like, I was gonna get...
I was gonna have to share revenue anyway.
Chat.
Like...
Like, I was gonna get striked anyway.
Might as well share the wealth.
With all the other companies.
Okay, bring the music down.
Don't worry, I got you.
Uh...
Alright.
Alright, it's time to make our...
Our character.
What do we...
Wait, what was the default?
Okay.
I could be like...
It's like I never went outside.
I never went outside and I got chucked into this world.
That's gonna be...
That's gonna be wor...
Wait, are we all like...
Oh, shit.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Are we all like...
Semi-bald?
Is that it?
Bella's a corpse?
I mean, we got the eyes correct.
Okay, head size.
Oh my god.
Okay.
And then...
What's the...
Oh my god!
What a fucking Chad!
Okay.
Yes.
Wait, I can literally make it Chad?
Holy shit!
Wait a minute!
Wait, this changes everything.
Wait a...
This changes everything!
Oh my god!
Is she mewing?
I finally did it!
Wait, okay.
I wanna be like semi-mewing.
Like, I'm still in the process of getting better at mewing.
Okay, what's the lower face with?
Alright, I need you guys to help me like read, too.
Because like people are typing in Chinese and I can't read.
So if they're like saying something that I should know, let me know.
Oh.
Oh!
Wait.
I don't know.
Okay.
Actually, I want that to be medium.
Because I actually really like...
Okay, we'll be like...
We'll have a smaller head because...
Uh...
No, actually...
Yeah, a semi-small head.
And...
Do I have to have abs?
Because like, I just...
Literally just went outside right now.
I went outside and I got chucked into the...
Apparently, this game has lore.
Apparently, there's an animated show that like appeared out of nowhere.
And it was like a star-studded cast.
And then everyone forgot about it.
Because it literally just came out of nowhere.
Like...
There was no advertising.
Oh my god.
There was like no advertising whatsoever.
But like, it was like the fucking...
The most star-studded cast ever.
Um...
Yeah, but like I heard that this game has like intense lore.
Okay, and then we don't have to worry about any of that.
Wait, hips.
Okay.
Yes.
And then...
I actually sort of want like nice thighs.
Ooh.
No.
Short king.
Short queen.
Ooh, yes.
Okay.
And then...
Or like chicken legs.
There you go.
Yeah.
I'm just like you guys, dragoons.
I'm just like all of you.
Uh...
Antonio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for sharing your hard-earned money with those poor multi-million dollar companies.
Truly insane.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Red Dog, thank you for the super chat.
I can't believe it's been three months since your return.
My brain rot in mine back then was imagining you do Heihachi walk up from Tekken 7 coming out of the red volcanic smoke completely danced up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Alright.
I think that's perfect.
Real...
Email...
Doki.
There you go.
Community survivor.
I think that's...
I think that's good.
If I'm too sh- like...
Uh...
If I'm too short, then like people will have a harder time hitting me.
Because like they'll aim for head level.
But like I'm so short that like my head level isn't head level.
So...
Ah!
Flashbang!
Alright, let's see.
Let's see how bad the ping is.
Alright.
To like halfway for having never paid attention to music.
Okay, let's make sure you're cold.
You should find some warmth soon.
Oh, okay.
Is there like free inventory?
Wait, what's this?
What the fuck are...
Is this free stuff?
Oh!
It's free stuff!
Right?
Did they give me free stuff?
Okay, let me like fix the sound real quick.
Okay.
Music...
Oh my god!
I get free stuff!
Dude, everybody's so nice!
Okay.
Uh...
How do...
Where's the fucking sense?
Where's the sense of...
Oh, there we go.
No camera shake, please.
Uh...
We're gonna turn that down.
Fucking hate camera shake.
I'm sorry.
I think camera shake is dumb.
I don't care about immersiveness.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, what can I take?
Oh, there's a...
Okay, I'm gonna take...
Wait, what is my...
Is this my inventory?
Wait, I already have armor.
Um, how do I open my inventory?
Is this...
Okay.
How do I...
Oh my god, I'm already overwhelmed.
Wait, why can't I put it on?
Did I put it on?
Or did I put it away?
No, I put it away.
What did I put...
This is it.
Oh, I can't...
I...
Oh, okay.
Oh my god, I'm beautiful.
Okay, equipped.
Okay, equip.
Equip.
Equipped.
Uh...
Wait, I have so many things.
That's crazy.
I have so many things.
Put this in my head.
I...
Your insert tutorial for...
Wait, I leveled up from existing!
God, I wish that was like real life.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Wait, what should I...
What should I get?
I leveled up just for existing!
I love it!
Uh...
I hope you have some knowledge of herbivores and carnivores.
If it looks threatening, it probably is.
Just beware, even if they're small...
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, what do I get?
HP?
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh.
I feel like I should get a pickaxe.
Oh, I got a pickaxe.
Right?
I wanna make a pickaxe.
That's what I want to make.
Alright guys...
Wait, there's stuff over there.
Alright guys, here we go.
There's so much...
Wait, there's colours over there.
Do you think that's a good colour?
Do you think that's friendly?
Hello?
Wait, there's so many colours around the world.
Wait, are those...
Are those friendly colors?
Are those...
Woah!
That must be friendly!
AHHHHH!
That's not fair!
I was following...
I was just...
I was just following the colors!
Nooooo!
All my items!
I had so many items!
I was rich!
Oh, I still have it.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god I still have it.
Hey guys, I still got it.
Nice.
Okay, everything's fine.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god, wait!
I can... I can have costumes and dodo birds?
How do I get the dodo bird?
Guys, I'm okay guys.
Alright.
Everything is okay.
We're off to a good start.
Guys...
I keep following the...
Guys!
Following the colors is very dangerous.
I'm like those flies that follow the bright colors.
You know like those flies that follow the zapper and you're like ooooooo Follow the zapper!
You're tired?
Stop moving?
Ooo pretty colors!
Wait, is this where I died?
Okay, we can easily fix this.
Wait, how the fuck...
AHHHH!
Wait, Santa Claus?
What is that?
It's okay.
We're back.
That's the fact.
Look!
It's still Santa!
I got distracted by Santa!
It's okay.
Round 3.
I got distracted by Santa!
I heard a ho ho ho!
Okay, let's turn up the gamma.
Alright.
I know a lot of you guys kept yelling at me to turn up.
Wait, how do you turn up gamma?
Where is that?
Where the fuck is that?
There's a gamma?
Can you actually...
Are you guys fucking with me?
Yeah, it's a tab.
I don't know if you guys are fucking with me.
Or if there's actual like...
It's oddly under key bindings.
It is?
Okay.
Where is it?
Oh, there you go.
Do we do gamma 1 or gamma 2?
Tab, type, gamma...
And type...
Should this be 3 or 4?
Oh wait, you guys can't see.
Is it gamma 1 or 2?
Guys...
Guys, which one is it?
1 or 2?
Yes.
Thanks.
That's very helpful.
Okay, I'm gonna put 3.
Alright.
That should be fine.
Okay.
Good.
Alright.
Did it fix anything?
Did it fix anything, guys?
Because I can't tell.
Oh, we bring down the music a little bit more.
Okay.
Bring it down a little bit more.
Yeah, I can't...
Oh, I didn't hit apply.
Sorry, I'm a little special.
There we go.
That should work.
Did it fix anything?
I should've asked Hiro to like help me explore note.
Oh my god, lore!
You might be.
I hope so.
It's been so many cycles since I was hurt.
Do I even still remember hope?
I wasn't sure you'd ever turn up.
That's me.
I'm here to save your life.
Don't mind about all the other dead Doki's behind me, but I'm here.
You can count on me.
I'm very reliable.
You have to reach me.
Everything depends on your survival.
My survival?
Master this well.
Whoa, bet on the wrong person.
I have to save you, Doki number one and two.
Did not do so well in this world.
Just like I did so long ago.
Never and find me, survivor.
Bad news.
You may be the only one who can.
But I'm not.
I'm not.
Me?
Really?
I'm the only one?
Oh shit.
Oh lore.
Okay.
Cool.
Where's the...
Where's my mouse?
Oh there it is.
Nice.
I got lore.
Oh level up is available?
Okay.
I can level up now.
Alright, what do we get guys?
Is it still health?
Is it...
Do we really need Gamma 4?
Do we really need... Wait.
Oh okay.
Okay, wait.
Yay!
Alright.
I leveled up.
I'm slowly learning.
Okay, let me...
Apparently people keep yelling at me to do Gamma 4.
Gamma 4.
Whoa!
Guys!
This is a whole different game.
Oh my god!
Whoa!
What the fuck?
This is a different game now.
We can see it now.
Holy shit.
Is this where I died like three times?
Or two times?
Oh yeah, that's definitely where I died two times.
The two time champion.
Alright.
I don't know where to go.
There's apparently like ten people on the server right now.
Alright.
Where do we... Ooh look!
Look at all the dinosaurs!
That's a herbivore!
Right there!
I know my dinosaurs!
That's a triceratops.
And then that's a brontosaurus.
You think I'll live?
Doki number three is gonna find out.
Oh!
Doki number three is okay.
Yay!
Ooh.
Doki number three is gonna figure out how to parkour this.
Uhhhh...
See?
Doki number three is learning from one and two!
This is bad.
Alright, here.
I'm gonna go to the other side.
Alright.
There's no way I die from this.
Alright, Doki number four coming in hot.
I keep getting inked.
Don't worry.
Doki number four has learned from all the mistakes from all the other Dokis.
All the other...
All the other Dokis.
They've learned.
They have learned.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
There's gonna be so much armor.
I don't know where to go.
Where's the map?
Oh, there's the map.
What the fuck?
That's just it?
That's just all the map?
That's me, right there.
Alright.
Is there like any way I can go?
I feel like I'm like locked in here.
Like, I feel like I'm actually locked in here.
I can touch nowhere else.
Alright.
Let's see.
Icing, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
There has to be like somewhere I can go.
How do I leave?
Punch a tree?
But I don't wanna live here.
I wanna find like a nice place to live.
Jesus Christ.
Those are all my dead bodies.
There's too many.
It's okay.
It's fine.
We'll figure this out live.
Oh, dragonflies!
Can I eat these?
Can I eat you guys?
Wait.
Wait, they hurt back?
Oh my god!
There's so many!
Oh.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
There is like a fucking clan!
Yeah.
Decomposes...
170?!
How the fuck do I farm you?
Oh, I got it.
I got raw meat!
From fucking insects?
Hey guys, I got some raw meat.
Wait, where are the other ones that I killed?
I swear.
There's like more.
It's okay.
Guys, I'm learning.
I got raw meat now.
I did it.
Yay!
Oh, I should punch some trees.
Oh, that's a lot.
What the fuck?
I'm strong as hell.
Oh my god.
Did you guys see that?
I'm so fucking strong.
Those look like herbivores.
Wait, all of them look like herbivores.
Except for that one raptor.
I can harvest a bush for berries.
But I'm not hungry yet, I think.
How do I get water though?
I wonder.
Wait, that doesn't look like a herbivore.
Why are they like the herbivores?
No, they're all herbivores.
They're all friends.
Guys, they're all friends.
Watch this guys.
Wait, this tree is still alive.
Oh, never mind.
Yay!
Bro, I'm so fucking strong.
Is that poop?
We might need this.
Wait, somebody dropped it.
Thank you.
I'm so sorry.
I can't believe they would waste good fertilizer like that.
Poop is good fertilizer.
Are you friend shaped?
It's fine.
He doesn't know how to fly.
Get over here.
You don't know how to...
I'm hungry.
I agree.
Oh.
Dine is canon.
And lord, you learn from your past life mistakes.
It's so funny.
Doki5 is canon.
Victory, thank you for the super chat.
I can't believe it.
It ran away.
Why would it run away from me?
I've been nothing but kind.
Oh, there's so many dinos.
Okay, let me look at my inventory.
Because I can upgrade again.
What should I get, guys?
Wait, I'm slowly Really starving.
Cook my meat?
But how do I make fire?
I haven't learned yet.
What do I get guys?
Weight?
Okay, I'll do more weight.
No, because then I'll get sick.
This is like good fertilizer.
I'm not gonna waste good fertilizer chat.
That's crazy.
Guys...
Where did my mouse go?
I... Oh, there it is.
I was like where the fuck did I...
Wait, I have so many points of...
Oh my god, I've leveled up so much.
Wait.
Speed, stamina, HP and weight.
Okay, stamina...
Speed...
Stamina... There's apparently like a lot of mods too for this game.
Okay.
Wait.
Is my stomach... Do I have issues?
Don't answer that.
Not speed?
But people are saying...
High level... Because I fucking destroyed a tree in one hit.
What do you mean?
Why do I need oxygen?
Just fucking breathe.
Let's see... A little bit of melee damage.
Okay, we have three more.
Speed till 200%?
You mean this?
Movement speed?
What about crafting?
Or fortitude?
What the fuck is fortitude?
Chemiris does matter now?
Oh, okay.
Upgrade my speed.
And then...
Just breathe.
I don't understand.
I still wanna make a...
Oh, I can make a stone hatchet.
Wait, I can make a gun?
Oh my god.
Guys, I can make a fucking gun.
Alright.
Just like Palworld.
What else can I make?
Let's see.
Well, I don't really need clothes.
I already have clothes.
Oh, I should get like a sleeping bag.
And then... Oh, a saddle!
I like saddles.
Oh, and a regular bed?
I learned so many.
Oh my god, look at all these things that I learned.
There's so much stuff.
I'm getting overwhelmed right now.
Alright, let's find a house.
I wanna be next to somebody.
Would it be rude if I make my...
If I make it next to somebody's house?
Where did I poop?
Is that my poop?
Pick up?
Sure.
I mean, it's good.
It's fertilizer.
I'm not gonna waste good old fertilizer.
Okay.
Am I hungry yet?
Okay, we need to make like...
How do I craft?
Alright.
Oh my god, look at all this fertilizer!
Wait, somebody dropped this!
Wait, somebody was next to me!
See?
Somebody dropped this!
They were next to me!
They dropped all this good-ass poop!
Look at that!
Okay, uh...
How do I craft, chat?
How do I...
How do I craft?
Oh my god.
You've been...
How did I get poisoned?!
Stop!
Bro!
I was just existing!
That's so fucked up!
Oh!
I was just existing!
No!
That's not fair!
I was starting to learn!
I just...
I just wanted to exist!
It's not fair!
That's not fair!
Doki number 5 is here!
I don't even know where Doki number 4 went!
Where did Doki number 4 go?
I can't believe I died to fucking up bullshit.
I'm so sad.
Doki number 5!
Doki number five!
Where did Doki number four die?
Doki number five has to figure this shit out.
Where the fuck did I die?
The drive-by!
I can't believe it!
Wait, Hiro's on!
You have made an enemy at the super save mega level bugs.
Doki is doomed!
Doki number four was doomed!
Doki number five still has a chance!
Wait, is this where I died?
This could be where I died.
There's so many dead bodies.
Wait, there's somebody else died to my right.
Alright, don't worry guys.
Doki number five is gonna be okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
It's not like the other... the others are not here to kill me.
What the fuck?
How are there still bugs?
How are you fucking camping my body?
Oh my god!
He's literally camping my body!
Bruh!
That's so fucked up.
That is so fucked up!
This is not fair!
Leave me alone!
I just want my life!
Welcome to the heart!
No!
Guys, Doki number six can clutch this.
Guys, I hate this area.
I hate this spot.
Don't worry.
Doki number six has figured stuff out.
Doki number six has figured it all out, guys.
Guys, do not worry.
Okay.
We're gonna get our shit back.
I'm just gonna look at the logs and it's just like Doki dead.
Doki has died.
Somebody made a fire!
Wait!
Who was here?
Somebody was just here and I missed them.
I can't believe it!
Somebody was just here and I actually missed them.
Okay.
Where did I die?
Wait.
Oh, there it is.
There's my stuff.
Doki 20 is not as far as I thought.
Okay.
The bugs can't hit you.
Are you prone?
That is so smart.
That's so smart.
Okay.
There's no way the bugs would be all the way here.
There's no fucking way.
Right?
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
No!
This is so fucked up!
Are you fucking... Bro, he's actually camping me!
Bro!
I'm so mad!
Oh my god!
Bro, let me have...
Bro, leave me alone!
Please!
I just want to...
My stuff!
Leave me alone!
No!
Insect 3.
Doki 0.
No!
I need...
Oh my god!
The worst part is like he's just slowly killing me.
He actually is just slowly fucking me up.
This is it.
Doki 7 has learned everything she could learn.
To fucking...
Um... beat Ark.
Not good at the whole...
Oh, I'm sorry!
There's like a fucking level 300 bug fucking camping my body.
Like, what the fuck do I do?
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's okay.
We'll be fine.
Doki 7 has figured things out.
Doki 8 is in a death loop.
Alright, don't worry.
We'll figure this out.
Oh my god.
It's so bright now.
There's no way it camps me again!
There's no fucking way!
Alright, we're gonna go around.
There he is!
There he fucking is!
He just flew above me like a little whore!
Okay, to be fair, all bugs are technically whores because like...
They make a lot of babies and they also fuck a lot.
So like, it's like scientifically accurate if you think about it.
Because all they do when they are born is just they wanna bang.
And then when they wanna bang and make babies.
So technically all insects are whores.
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god I got my shit back.
Doki what?
It's true!
The moment they're like outside...
The moment they're like outside the pupa stage.
All they wanna do is bang.
So scientifically all insects are whores.
We will not listen to this slander.
Holy shit!
I cannot see!
Okay, I need a fucking gamma 3 or some shit.
This is way too bright for me.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do I go?
Wait, is that friend?
That's a bear.
Wait.
Are you friend?
Hello?
Do you...
Oh my god!
I'm getting flash banged.
Wait, can I... Can they be my pet?
You wanna be... Do you wanna join me?
Do you wanna join me?
Why are you running away?
I want... I want him to...
Check settings.
Oh, I can turn off bloom?
Okay guys, thank you.
Where's bloom?
Motion blur.
Oh, light bloom.
Yeah, fuck that.
That is terrible.
Oh my god.
That's a lot better.
Okay.
I need a... No!
Oh, okay.
It's fine.
We can... We'll be okay.
Okay.
Craft slingshot to knock out and tame a dino?
Wait, how do you craft guys?
I still have not figured out how to craft stuff.
Wait, there's somebody's box over here.
It was like red.
I'm dehydrated?
Find water?
That's not friend.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, hey.
Who's that?
Hello?
We are
flying.
Wait.
Oh my god.
I'm dying of thirst right now.
Do you have any water?
Oh, you want to drink?
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
I died like seven times.
I don't know how to play this game.
Okay.
New player.
There's water.
How do I...
Oh my god.
I'm okay now.
Yeah.
I died seven times.
Can I like steal your...
Hey.
How do I get on?
Oh.
Yeah.
We're in like a trap right now.
Oh, shit.
Do you want to come in?
Do you want to join our tribe?
Yeah.
I want to join your tribe.
Will you take care of me?
Are you guys going to take care of me and feed me?
Please.
I'm baby.
I need to be fed and watered.
Oh my god.
It's so cute.
Can he die?
Yeah.
It's an otter.
He can die.
Oh.
He's walking around because Nat's like loading the map.
Because he's... he hasn't walked around the map yet.
So she's like loading the map right now.
Oh.
Okay.
How do I join your tribe?
Oh.
Hold... Oh.
Okay.
Accept invitation.
Try baka?
Try with baka?
Yeah.
I call baka.
Don't burp me.
It's okay.
We're not baka.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Your boobs.
Baka.
It's...
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Yeah.
I touched a natan.
I don't know why she's so tiny.
Oh my god.
She's so...
I can't stop looking.
Oh my god.
For free?
Oh.
Don't worry.
Here.
I'll pay you.
I'll pay for it.
Here.
This is my payment.
I'll give this to you.
Okay.
I'll give it to you.
Here.
Oh.
Vampire Dodo.
Is that clothes?
Oh.
For a swimsuit.
Yeah.
You can pack it up to be clothes.
And you'll look like a skin.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's see.
Wait.
How do I...
How do I put it on?
Drag it onto your card and clothes.
What?
How do I put this on?
I can only drop it.
You drag it onto your clothes.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm hot now.
Look at me.
Oh.
Am I hot?
Am I sexy?
Sexy.
Yeah, Nachan?
Am I sexy?
Sexy.
Oh.
Don't worry.
I can take it off for you, Nachan.
You're so cute.
We're heroes wives.
I'll strip for Aida.
I can take it all off if I can have this mount.
Wait.
I'm like, full eggs, by the way.
We were like, earlier, we were just eating car and you were giving us wide-eared eggs.
Then, like, last night, I was like, do you...
Oh my god.
You're like cutting in and out for me.
Wait.
My audio?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Why?
Is it like the server?
Like...
Okay.
No.
I...
Me.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
You're like a robot.
I don't want it to be.
I think you're...
Chatel.
Hey.
Wait.
Where's your...
Show me your house.
I want to see your house.
You don't join...
Hold E.
Hold E?
Oh.
Okay.
I thought I joined you guys.
Oh.
Wait.
How come it won't let me?
Oh.
There you go.
I got it.
Did I join you guys?
Oh.
Yeah.
Now we're like...
Right?
It's easier to be.
Oh.
Yeah.
I'm part of your team.
Uh -huh.
Don't you know I'm a fighter.
I'm a
fighter.
You're welcome.
That's a...
Let's go.
Oh.
Pick me up.
It's so cold.
How do I...
Okay.
Oh my God.
I can fly.
It's beautiful.
Wait.
Can you guys help me kill a bug?
I... I want...
No.
This bug killed me like seven times.
This bug killed me seven times.
We got beat him up.
I have a team now.
Here.
It's like right here.
It's right here.
We got to find this bug.
I want to kill this bug.
Give me a sec.
Where is he?
This bug has killed me seven times.
I need revenge.
Where is he?
This is my... all my bodies.
Where the fuck is that bug?
I'm so sad.
Where is he?
It was like...
It was like level 300.
I'm dead.
Where is he?
Guys, where is the bug?
Guys, chat.
Help me find the bug.
We need to kill him and teach him a fucking lesson.
He's gone?
No.
Okay.
He's gone.
He despawned.
I'm so mad.
I finally can kill him.
All right.
Pick me up.
Pick me up!
Okay, okay, okay!
Yeah!
Oh shit!
Woo!
Oh my god!
Wait, I can't...
Oh my god, look at me go!
Oh!
You're a natural!
Am I like on push to talk or like voice activation?
Can you guys hear me?
Okay, I'm definitely on push to talk.
I was making sure to chat if I was on push to talk or voice activation.
Because I didn't... I did not look at my...
Oh, I can zoom out!
Oh!
Look at me go!
Guys, I'm like the eye candy for the tribe.
It gave me like a bikini and now I know my place.
It's okay, don't feed...
Guys, they're gonna feed me and shelter me!
Guys!
They're gonna feed me and shelter me and they gave me free transportation!
Oh my god, the fucking...
Flashbang.
They're not gonna drop me guys.
Whoa!
What is that?
Is that a horse?
Wait, is that... whose house is that?
Oh, we... our like house.
Is that your house?
The one over there?
No, no, no, it's over here.
Oh my god.
Wait, is that...
Is that the house?
What the fuck?
Okay, this looks...
It's not really our house.
It's like a place where we can like...
Oh, it's a store where all the pets and stuff?
Yeah, we can just leave the good stuff there.
Like inside there's like stuff.
Oh!
Oh my god, there's so many pets!
Can they die?
They can die.
Wait, if I actually stab them, they'll die?
Yeah, they'll get hurt.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I think you should heal your otter.
I stabbed your otter earlier.
On accident.
Oh my god, there's so many!
Oh my god, there's an owl!
There's so many pets.
I want to catch the...
The what?
Is it like a...
version of the T-Rex?
Oh!
What level is it?
300.
Oh, we can kill it.
I believe in them.
I believe in us.
We don't know the rules!
We can do it.
Oh my god, who's this guy?
Who's Della?
Della?
Yeah, she's another...
She's a VTuber.
She sings a lot.
Oh!
She should do a concert for us.
Oh my god, do you guys farm these animals for poop?
Uh...
Della's so cool.
I think she's farming poop.
Yeah, I was gonna say!
Is she farming them for poop?
Oh my god.
Guys, I have a house now!
Guys!
I have a house and I didn't have to work for it!
I love it here.
Oh.
The poop fire.
Oh my god.
I want my poop.
I want my own... I want my own mount.
Wait, I... Oh yeah, I have to make a bed!
Okay, guys.
Alright, I need to get a bed.
Wait, I'm gonna die of thirst.
I just realized.
I am so thirsty.
Uhhhh...
Where's the water?
Oh, there it is.
Consume.
Alright, not thirsty anymore.
Let's go.
I'm a squatter?
I'm not a squatter!
I provide, like, entertainment!
Guys...
It gave me a bikini!
I'm trying to thirst.
Yeah, yeah, I'm really... Yeah, I need water.
Yeah.
Also, they...
Actually, this is really nice.
Oh my god.
Level 300?
Who the fuck caught that?
To catch...
Oh, yeah.
I wanna catch, like, a flying thing too.
Oh, food.
Yeah, not...
I don't need food.
I'm starving, apparently.
Yeah, I'm hungry.
Oh, okay.
Do I just swim and then I drink water?
Oh, nice!
I'm learning.
Oh!
How do I...
Oh my god, I'm glitching out!
I'm here.
Oh!
I'm okay!
Alright.
This...
Yeah...
There's, like, a thousand water bottles...
...in a big, big thing.
Wait, are you dying?
Oh, what?
She's bleeding!
What the fuck?
Here's the...
Where's the food?
You...
Food's okay.
I'll feed you.
Feed me.
I'm baby.
Oh, nice!
Alright.
I think we need to start by...
...going to the beach.
Oh my god, our beach episode.
Beach episode.
Yeah, we're having our beach episode right now.
What the fuck?
Did you... She's catching it.
Put food in inventory to tame.
I didn't give it food.
So, to tame something, you can put...
...meat or berries in your inventory...
...of your safe.
Yeah?
You wanna try?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I put food in this inventory.
Is it...
Is it taming?
Oh, it needs berries?
Yeah, I'll give it to you.
Do I have berries?
It's
five minutes.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
You put the meat in it...
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, and then it'll eventually become my friend?
Yeah.
So, it's taming is...
...percent now, right?
Oh, he hit it!
He left it in the...
...taming.
Oh, oops.
I'm stuck.
Guys, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck!
No!
Oh, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Is he...
You wanna be friend?
Oh, 63%!
Okay.
Yay!
Friend!
Oh my god.
Wait, you can make babies with them!
Because... right?
Because they...
...female.
Oh!
Do you guys have the female?
Can my male...
Can my male guy bang your female and make...
...female.
I don't have a female.
I don't have a male.
Okay, 63%.
Hello.
Well, this is just a normal one.
You don't have to...
...uh...
...s in it.
You
don't have to...
Oh, I see, I see.
I'm learning.
...like...
...and he's like...
Oh, I see.
I
have a dragon!
I'm playing.
Oh my god, look guys!
It's you, dragons!
That's you!
No!
No, I'm sorry!
Oh, he's flying away!
Why is he flying away?
I'm so sorry!
Oh, saddle.
Equip saddle...
...to ride.
Do I have a saddle?
Oh, do you guys have a saddle?
Yeah!
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Uhhh...
...
Where's the saddle?
Is it this one?
What the fuck is it called?
Okay, what is it called, dragon?
What are you guys called?
You guys are...
...
Okay, yeah, I'm not... I'm only level 17.
I'm just baby.
Alright, dragon!
Come on, dragon!
Get over here!
Come on!
That's right!
...
What?
It was an accident!
Guys, I didn't stab you guys!
It was a dream!
I gave you guys a pet!
I pet you guys.
I like, gave you a little pet.
Oh my god.
...
I would never...
...chat.
You were literally the first thing I tamed.
I gave you guys a little head pad.
That red was...
...just berries.
Yeah, it's called... I gave you guys like...
...you know, like hazing?
I like...
...
You know, I hazed you guys.
Oh, okay.
Yeah!
Let's take her in.
Natchan Natchan, grip me!
Pick me up!
Yay!
...
Where is my pet?
Where's my dragoons?
My dragoons, why aren't you following me?
Dragoons, why aren't you following- ...
It's safe!
...
Where's... we're gonna go to a new home, guys.
Can she like accidentally drop me?
Oh my god, look at all these other dragoons over there.
Where's Hiro?
Wait, where's Hiro?
Hiro!
Hiro, where are you?
Nachan's lost!
Yeah, I was like, I didn't even know where you were.
Wait, so you guys have two homes?
You guys have two houses?
Oh my god, is that the real house?
On the left?
Is that the real... oh.
Wait, can we... can we invade it?
Yeah!
Holy shit, why can't our house...
Are they here?
Oh my god!
Hello!
Say your English!
Your English!
I can speak a little English.
What?
Hiro, Hiro!
Hello!
Hiro!
You have a strong accent.
Nice.
I like it.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Hiro!
They gave me a bikini.
So now they take care of me, now.
Oh!
Can I... your house is beautiful!
Can I join your tribe?
Really?
Will you join your tribe?
Yeah, yeah, can I...
I can join Hiro's family.
But they have a gun.
Hiro, where's your gun?
Hiro?
Okay, okay.
Hiro!
They said they wanted to go in your room.
Yes, I said why not go in your room?
They don't have guns.
They have guns but they don't shoot us.
You have guns?
Oh sorry.
They don't shoot us.
It's okay, I was joking here.
I would never leave your tribe.
It was a joke.
I can't give you too much things but I can give you a few.
Thank you!
Oh my god, thank you!
Don't be hungry.
Thank you for taking care of me.
Don't worry, I'll dance for you.
I'll dance for you.
Don't worry.
Here, you wanna see the back?
Oh, okay.
Guys, their house is so much better!
No shame!
What the fuck!
Oh my god!
That's beautiful!
She will... she will...
She will... burn a baby after two minutes.
Really?
Can I keep the baby?
Just wait two minutes.
Okay.
Can I watch it?
Yeah.
Yeah, of course.
Oh my god!
They gave me a hundred fucking...
Me!
Hiro would never...
You can join my group first.
And try to...
Little... little monkey.
Oh my god, where's the baby?
And you will see.
Oh!
Yeah.
And you will see.
Like, hold E.
Yeah, yeah.
And join my team.
And then take the baby.
When you want to change, you just click it.
Oh, I see!
Yeah.
You don't mind.
Just click it.
You want to join others, it's fine.
Oh, yeah.
But now you join me group, you can like...
Try to like...
Oh my god!
Oh!
That is so cool!
You join my group and you can try it.
That's so cool!
Wait, I can?
Yeah, you...
Press E.
Oh, A.
Okay.
To... yeah, E to...
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh my god!!
Oh my god!
Look at me go!
Hero can never...
It's so f****** cool!
You can try this new dragon, yeah.
Oh my god!
Look at me go!
Go
around.
Go around.
Yea, yea.
Yea, yea, yea.
Oh, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Oh no, I'm stuck.
I'm okay.
Alright, nice.
Parkour!
Oh my god!
Look at me go!
Guys!
Guys, I think I have a new family now.
Guys, I think I found a new family.
Wait, can I slap him?
Oh my god!
Get over here.
Monkey supreme.
Monkey supreme!
Bam!
That's fucking right.
Get out of here!
Get out!
I'm having a good time.
Try to press... left button.
Try to press...
left button.
Oh, left button?
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Try to press the C.
The key button C.
Oh, let's see.
Oh my god!
I'm so strong!
What doesn't Hiro have this?
I will be strong!
I will be just as strong.
Oh my god!
Let me just kill everything.
Holy sh... Guys!
Guys!
Oh!
I did a thousand damage!
We can't win this!
Do you want to go back to see the baby?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I wanna see the baby!
Yeah, let's go back to see the baby!
Yeah!
To see the baby!
Guys.
This house is insane.
Oh my god!
This house is... guys...
My new family.
Oh my god!
Look at the baby!
Ab- fucking... baby~~~~ Is the baby coming out?
Wait!
Oh shit.
I'm sorry!
He's like... He's like my baby...
And I'm so sorry.
You just... you just press T...
Oh T?
Okay!
Okay.
You're not my baby anymore.
Wait.
Oh... oh.
How do I... How do I... How do I disown it?
No!
What?
What happened?
What's going...
Okay, I'm not your mom.
Leave.
I'm not your mom.
T?
Okay.
Oh, there I see it.
Stop.
How do I disown it?
Oh, unclaim!
Unclaim!
There you go.
I got it.
He's not my... I disowned it.
You have to take me with you.
Can you... Can you...
He's not... He's not... He's not your child anymore.
He's not my child anymore.
Okay, okay.
Wait, no, he is!
He's still my kid.
I don't want you.
Can you unclaim?
Oh, I claimed it.
I unclaimed it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Option.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Wait, I'm doing it now.
Okay, okay.
You're not my baby anymore.
I don't want you.
Okay.
Okay, how do I join back to you?
Oh, okay, here you go.
That's a tryout and it's a really nice game.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you for letting me...
Letting me join your team.
It's Hei Wu Xiang.
Hei Wu Xiang.
This is like my first time playing.
Yeah, my first time.
It's not your first time.
It's her first time.
Yeah.
Thank you again.
Thank you for letting me ride the gorilla.
Have a nice time.
You too.
Thank you.
Welcome to my home.
Your home is beautiful.
It's beautiful.
Wait, open.
Nan-chan.
Yeah, pick me up.
Nan-chan, are you okay?
This is also funny.
Oh, Doki-san.
Oh.
Can you see the things, the green here?
Can you come, come, come?
Yeah.
Come, please.
Come, come, come.
I'm here.
It can like two people.
Oh, oh.
Just come here.
Wait a minute.
Oh my God.
It's so beautiful.
Hello.
Oh my God.
Guys.
I love being spoiled.
It's really nice.
It's so nice.
Oh my god, thank you.
You will have it.
One day I'll be just as rich as you guys.
Alright, bye bye!
Alright, pick me up, pick me up.
I'm like a princess.
Did you miss?
Come on, Nachan!
Yay!
Bye bye!
See you!
Thank you again!
Bye bye!
Oh my god, they're so nice.
Guys, are you guys as rich as them?
I thought we were going to your house.
Wait, what?
I thought he followed me.
Wait, we can pick up the saddle.
We can pick up the saddle at your place, and then go back.
We can go back.
We tried to follow him.
Oh my god, everyone is so nice.
Everyone is so nice.
They are treating me so well.
Wait.
Wait, can he...
No, wait.
That can happen?
That is what?
Oh, they have to restart the server.
It's okay.
We can get a new dragoon.
We'll get new dragoons, guys.
It's fine.
And pretend that we never lost you.
You know, it's like how like... people would...
Okay, it's so fucked up for me to say.
But like... you know...
There's like people that actually do that.
Where they'll just buy the same pet.
And then you just rename it.
And then it's like they never died.
So like some people have done that.
Where they'll be like...
My pet is like 80...
It's like the oldest living pet in the world.
Like 70 plus years old.
But then like the mom would just secretly replace it every time.
And just name it the same thing.
So we're gonna do that.
What?
I don't get it.
They cut the shot.
Whoa.
Are you the king?
Yeah.
What?
Don't say what.
So this is not really our home.
It's a temporary place.
Oh.
Don't say anything.
It looks like shit.
It looks...
Look, our members are not here.
It looks amazing.
Dude, we're separated.
It's not...
Wait, this house?
It's okay.
So...
What?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's over here.
Oh.
This is...
You know what?
It looks amazing.
I love it.
You're gonna open this?
See?
Wait, what is this?
You're just...
Oh, I'm too low.
It's secure, bitch.
Oh, yeah.
I'm too...
I'm too low level.
Look.
Come here.
So, what about the story?
Yeah?
So this is where everybody starts, basically.
Uh-huh.
So, Natchan just started.
She's not really high level yet.
And she took somebody else's house.
This is actually somebody else made this.
Woah!
What the fuck?
Oh yeah, this is somebody's...
Personal owner, Kuru Kuru.
This is beautiful.
Wait, and then...
Oh, she just put it in her... It was like somebody else's house.
Wait, this is Natchan's house!
It's very tiny because she just started.
Wait, I should eat.
Give me a sec, let me eat.
I don't know if this is like, scared or... Take you somewhere else.
Oh yeah.
But like, basically, they stay here.
My house is bigger than...
It's like, it's like...
...a cool, uh, here, like, area.
Oh, this is your house?
Yeah, I stay up here.
This is where...
...I have nothing here yet.
Oh!
What is this?
Oh, it's a grill!
Oh!
You make food here.
You can't have weapons, but... Yeah, this is a...
Oh my god.
One day I'll be just as rich.
I thought I fell down.
Oh, I'm here by the way.
Oh my god.
You can drink water, like, right here.
Oh, wait, is this like, uh...
...like a fountain?
Yeah, I...
Oh, I see.
I'm learning so much.
Like, specifically, I'll show you...
...the...
...VT?
Yeah.
Yeah, look, I've hidden all the pipes in.
I should connect to the...
Oh, yeah, so they... so it looks prettier.
Yeah, it looks pretty ugly if you don't hide it.
Oh, I see.
And it's my breeding ground.
Your breeding ground?!
Oh my god!
Wait, what's this Santa thing?
Oh, it's an event.
What is it?
It's a special event.
He'll draw friends from the sky and you can open them.
Oh!
I see.
And, uh, weapons and all that.
And...
Oh my god.
What are you trying to breed?
Oh, he is playing.
Oh, you're gonna eat their babies?
That's so weird.
Oh, there's food right here.
Oh no, that's poop.
That's poop, nevermind.
I thought that was...
Oh, so you can eat the dodos.
You can make the chicken.
Ba dum bum, bum bum bum.
Oh my god.
Oh!
I'm learning so much chat.
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Yay!
No, I'm okay.
Just a little bit.
A forbidden nugget.
You know what?
The reason why dodo birds are extinct is because apparently they're really delicious.
That people just ate all of them.
Ooh.
Yeah, they're really stupid, but also delicious.
Apparently.
They're like... they're like grade A.
Like, you know how there's like Kobe... Kobe beef and stuff like that?
Like, it's basically like the chicken equivalent of like Kobe beef.
I actually know they weren't...
How do you know?
You've never had a fucking dodo bird.
Like, how would you know?
They died before you were born.
Kobe bird.
You can't be like, they weren't that delicious.
You literally weren't even born when they were tied up.
How do I know?
Because there were books about it!
There were fucking books written about it!
And they said that like dodo birds were delicious.
Oh, oh my god.
What the fuck is that?
What is that?
Oh my god!
Who... what is that?
That's actually... wait, I feel like I might die from cold.
I'm gonna freeze to death.
Give me a sec.
Let me... let me...
I'm only wearing a bikini.
Oh my god!
Look at it!
Holy shit!
What the fuck is that?
Is it cute?
What?
I mean...
I... no?
No!
Is this cute?
How is this cute?
This is pretty cute!
It's... it's... it's so... it's so... it's so big and cute.
I don't know.
It looks fluffy.
What even is this?
You can probably get this bag by...
Oh my god.
Dude, this guy owns so many bugs.
This guy...
Look at this.
Here.
What is this?
What the fuck?
Is he sleeping in there?
What?
He's in the kingpin.
Oh my god.
What the...
They captured these people.
Oh my god.
He has prisoners?
I don't wanna make him into...
This person... this person that lives here is a crazy...
He's crazy?
He is... he is... he... sounds like... very... like... cute sounding.
But he's crazy.
He's crazy.
I mean, he's keeping prisoners.
Prisoners.
Yeah.
I think he actually jailed... you know the girl that...
Hey, Lu Xiang.
Oh, your mic is cutting in and out again.
Oh, can you hear me now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, the girl earlier that was... Hey, Lu Xiang.
The one that gave you the gorilla?
Yeah.
Like, pour it to... like... handcuffed her.
So...
The handcuffed her?
Yeah.
He handcuffed her as well.
Like, he's kinda crazy.
Oh my god!
Bro!
Thank god he's not online right now.
I think he's gonna... I think he might like...
I think he is online.
Oh, he is?
Let me see.
Oh my god.
I don't want him to like... put me in jail.
I'm scared.
He has like actual prisoners.
Yeah.
Not sure.
I'm scared.
What the fuck?
What happened to the fucking moose?
How do they...
He has like a baby creature.
I gotta eat again.
I'm hungry again.
I'm always hungry.
Holy shit.
Guys, I don't wanna go to jail.
Guys, I'm scared.
Oh my god.
There's so many different kinds of animals though.
Bro, this guy has like a fucking museum.
He has a museum.
Did I stole something?
I don't... I don't even know if I did.
Huh?
What's going on?
What does that mean?
Wait, Nachan is screaming.
Yeah, Nachan.
Are you okay?
What's going on?
What is that?
Hello?
My god.
His dodo birds are so high level.
No.
This is... enemy birds by the way.
Oh yeah.
I was like wondering what that was.
Sorry, the enemy.
It's just...
It's just dodo birds.
Yeah.
I think it's a vet.
He's not the... He's not that guy, right?
The prisoner guy?
He's just here?
No, no, no.
This is Tsukikaze.
Yeah.
He typed.
I don't think he has... He's using my account now.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I was like scared that it was him.
But Coryx is on though.
He is on?
Okay.
I think he's somewhere.
He's somewhere.
He's somewhere...
I'm sorry.
I think there is more people.
The thing is he drops like... enemy...
Wait.
He drops stuff into your house?
What?
Oh my god.
He's so scary.
Do you think he'll be my friend?
You think he'll be my friend?
Yeah.
He will.
Hello.
Wei, wait.
We need to restart.
But I don't know if they will restart.
I don't dare to play again.
There's like a bug?
Oh, that's weird.
That's weird.
Oh my god, this guy actually has a fucking zoo.
That's actually crazy.
Alright, we might have to... we might have to...
We're going to restart the server.
It's been a nice tour though.
I'm enjoying looking around the art server.
I haven't learned much.
I didn't really learn how to play.
But like, I'm having a good time exploring.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
It's been a fun tour.
I've been enjoying seeing everybody's houses.
Because the server has been up for like a week, I think.
Yay!
And they let me see the gorilla.
I get to join somebody's squad.
Like, I get to join somebody's like OP fucking team.
Woo!
Yeah, did all this in like... a week.
Yeah.
Wait, is King Kong... that...
Is King Kong actually that insane to get?
Oh my... guys...
My first day and I already had a King Kong baby.
But then I left, I disowned it.
Because I'm not ready to be a parrot.
Guys, I'm so good at vid... I'm so good at video games.
On my first day, I got a King Kong.
I get to ride a King Kong.
You're fully groomed.
Wait, Nachan.
Wait, where did Nachan go?
Nachan!
I went to get milk.
And left the... and left King Kong.
Nachan!
Wait, I think she's actually lost.
Lost.
Woah, did somebody build this?
Wait, Hiro?
Oh.
Oh, they restarted the server.
Guys, I think the server got...
I don't know if... if Hiro DCs and I fucking fall...
I swear to God.
Oh, I hope it's a restart.
Oh, no.
Oh, oh, oh.
What's going on?
Oh.
No!
Oh,
oh, oh.
I love her, he's wild.
Hey, he...
Oh.
I was so scared!
No, I'm not dead!
Holy shit!
That was so scary!
Oh my god!
I was like, oh no!
She's scaring me!
I'm so fucked!
No!
If I don't...
Guys!
I can't die!
If I...
I can't die, guys!
There's no way!
Okay.
Apparently the server is back up.
Alright, join.
Guys, it's okay.
I left before I touched the ground.
So technically, I'm still alive.
Technically.
It'll be okay.
We're searching for...
I'm searching for the session right now.
Wait, where is it?
Favorites...
I can't find...
The server is still not up yet.
It says people are...
You know what?
I can enter now.
Until you hit the ground.
If I never...
If I never get back on, I'll still be alive.
Oh, they're...
Not yet?
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick then.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Apparently at the...
Let me see refresh.
Someone said to re-add the server because they restarted it.
Alright, let me re-add the server.
Okay.
Let me find it again.
Give me a sec.
I'm learning.
I'm having fun though.
Everybody is so friendly.
I like that.
I like it when people are nice.
Oh, it needs 10 minutes.
Never mind.
We still need 10 more minutes.
To restart the server.
So, we'll just chill a little bit.
But...
It's pretty chill.
I really want to meet the criminal.
The crazy guy.
Really?
I gave it back.
I didn't realize I took the egg.
I was so used to just pressing E on stuff.
But I dropped the egg.
I dropped the egg before...
Before...
Before I kept it.
But...
I want to meet the crazy guy.
That's been locking people up.
I know that Kiro's mic has been really fucking weird.
Because she was telling us how her PC is sort of low-key dying.
And...
She was saying how... I don't know if you guys heard it.
But she was saying how...
People were like...
The crazy guy...
Was dropping enemies into other people's homes.
Just to fuck with them.
And I was like...
Man, I'm a troll.
But that is like... at a next level.
I was just like...
Oh my god.
That is next level.
I'm fucked up.
They actually dropped enemies onto other people's homes.
I was like...
Oh my god.
No wonder Kiro was like...
Yeah, he's crazy.
I wanted him.
He had like a cages of three different people.
He had like...
Cages of three fucking people.
Just sleeping there.
Next to like...
Apparently he's on the server.
And Kiro was saying like...
Yeah, he's doing something.
So I was just like...
What is he?
He's a little scary.
I'm not gonna lie.
They are the people...
No, he did that to Kiro's house.
He did that to Kiro's house.
That's why I was like...
Oh my god.
That's a whole next level.
What is he cooking?
And he was saying how...
He was saying like...
Several people.
Did you hear that?
He handcuffed several...
He handcuffed the girl that gave me a gorilla.
Gave me King Kong.
Why did he do it though?
Because he's a fucking troll.
Because he's crazy.
Apparently.
But yes, I've been enjoying.
I can't believe the first thing Kiro...
One of the first things Kiro gave me...
Was water and a bikini.
And then at that point I knew my place.
Hahaha.
Look I died seven times.
Guys.
I fucking died.
Seven times.
To a god damn insect.
I need this.
I need someone to take care of me.
Hahaha.
Because I got...
I died to that fucking mosquito.
Seven different times.
Hahaha.
And I never got my revenge.
Every single time.
Hahaha.
It's okay.
It's alright.
Guys.
People are so nice though.
That girl that...
The one with all the animals.
And she let me join their tribe for like...
Five minutes.
So I would know what it feels like to be rich in Ark.
Like...
Hahaha.
I get to feel the wealth in Ark for like...
Five, ten minutes.
That was nice.
Hahaha.
And then she was gonna like...
She wanted to give me that gorilla.
And I felt bad.
Cause I was like no it's okay.
Let me just like go for milk.
Like go out like...
No, no.
You don't need to give me the gorilla.
It's okay.
Let me go out and you know...
Go out and get some milk.
Her base...
Her base was not ugly.
I've seen an ugly base.
But not Hiro's base.
Hiro's base was very pretty.
Hahaha.
She gave me...
She gave me prehistoric Mercedes.
Yeah.
And I was like...
Oh my god.
Hahaha.
Uh...
It was insane.
But then I felt like...
You know I was just like...
I don't know man.
Guys I...
Hahaha.
Alright.
Let's see.
Uh...
Sorry.
We're waiting for the servers.
I think after I see the house...
I'm gonna try to tame another dragoon.
Wait no.
I'm gonna tame my first dragoon.
Because I never tamed a creature yet.
So uh...
I never tamed a creature yet.
So I wanna test it.
Try it out.
And then see...
And then we'll call it there.
Hahaha.
Yeah the server is still not up.
I'll be like okay.
Let me know when it's...
Let me know.
I'm just chatting with my...
With my dragoons.
Start with a dota or something easy?
No!
I wanna pterodactyl.
And call it a dragoon.
I've never tried it before.
Uh...
They said like 10 minutes.
Do not believe her lies.
What am I lying about?
I've never tamed anything in this game before.
I've never tamed anything.
Aphelion thank you for the 10 gift of ships.
Thank you.
No it's pterodactyl.
It's pterodactyl.
How would you know?
They don't even...
They're gonna fucking come back from extinction.
To tell you what they're actually called.
Like...
Hahaha.
You're dead!
They can't tell you what they're actually called.
The P is silent.
No it's pterodactyl.
Guys.
It's always been pterodactyl.
It's like dodo birds.
You don't know what the fuck they taste like.
They...
Historical records...
Oh yeah someone tried to actually eat me.
Uh garlic thank you for the super chat.
Historical records indicate that they didn't taste very good.
But they were eaten to extinction because it was the only meat around for miles.
Like they would park boats on the island to eat them.
Wait what?
They would park boats?
There's like other... there's fish.
Fish?
What were fish then?
Like what were fish?
Hahaha.
No they described it as tough but good.
And like some hunted dodos only for the gizzards.
Because the most delicious part of the bird.
Yeah see I told you.
You can't actually meet.
Wikipedia which is the best source of information.
It's like a list of uh...
Yeah see there's always people saying dodos must have tasted...
Uh...
See like okay some people say...
Look it's like preferences.
Some are like oh it wasn't that great.
But then others are saying that...
Um they were good.
Hahaha.
Let's see.
How big were dodos?
They were like 40 pounds?
Oh my god they were like bigger than turkeys.
Dodos were modern animals.
Mid 17th century.
Taking straight.
Blue parrots are very numerous as well as other birds.
Their birds lacked wings.
Blah blah blah.
Nevertheless their belly and breasts were of a pleasant flavor.
See?
Look at that.
Okay.
Nevertheless their belly and breasts were of a pleasant flavor.
There you go.
There you go guys.
I told you guys.
It's all about preferences.
Some people don't like beef.
There.
But then yet they still eat it.
So others will eat anything that isn't hard tacked.
That's true.
That's so true.
Stream tack education.
To be fair.
I hate turkey.
I don't understand why people like to eat turkey.
Because I find turkey to be like very dry.
And uh.
Not like flavorless.
You have to put like fucking gravy or something.
To make it taste like gravy.
You need to put actual like gravy.
And like cranberries.
To actually make it like taste like something.
But like I feel like turkey is very dry.
Not dry.
I mean turkey is very flavorless in general.
Yeah.
I think like turkey is inferior chicken.
It truly is.
I mean they're stupid.
I mean to be fair.
Chicken is like.
Like.
Just that stupid.
But turkey is like.
It's like turkeys we domesticated them so hard.
That like.
Like have you seen like the size of a turkey brain?
Size of.
Turkey brain.
They're very.
Yeah.
It's like a pea.
That's like how tiny it is.
It's like the size of a fucking pea.
That's so tiny.
Yeah.
It's pea size.
Wow.
Turkeys.
Yeah.
But like I'm talking about like.
It's the same thing.
Like of course.
Domesticated turkeys are.
Are really stupid because.
You know they've been bred to.
How stupid are domesticated.
Domesticated.
Turkeys.
Sorry I had like a little brain fart.
Where I couldn't even spell domesticated.
Uhhhh.
Let's see.
Okay.
Alright wild turkeys are very intelligent animals.
What the fuck do we do?
Hahahaha.
Wait.
Apparently.
They used to be highly intelligent animals.
What the fuck do we do to the turkey?
Oh my god.
Hahahaha.
They used to be smart.
Oh my god it's like me.
I used to be smart.
And then I started streaming.
I used to have.
Like I used to have a professor that like.
Uh really liked me and said I was really smart.
And then.
I don't know what happened.
I just started streaming.
Hahahaha.
I did higher education.
We bred them harder than.
Art players ever could.
Hahahaha.
Alright.
Oh.
We're just waiting.
Uh.
We're just waiting for the serve.
At the moment.
Boop boop boop.
We're just waiting.
The day Doki's brain shrunk three sizes.
So true.
Hahahaha.
Woah.
Sorry.
I don't know if my chrome.
Wait is my chrome.
Oh good my chrome is not on.
Okay thank god you guys didn't hear it.
Hahahaha.
Let me refresh and see if the server is back up.
I know I did say like I told.
Hero to let me know.
But the server is still not back up.
Yeah so the reason why they had to restart the server.
Is because apparently.
Somebody did something that bugged the whole server.
So they're trying to figure out.
They couldn't figure out what.
Who did it.
I guess.
I guess they couldn't figure out who.
It wasn't me.
Because it was happening before I was there guys.
It was happening before.
Me out joined.
So what did I do.
I literally all I did was I died.
Three times to gravity.
And then like three times to a fucking mosquito.
Like what did I do.
Hahahaha.
What did I do.
Anyway.
Um.
So they're saying that somebody.
Bugged.
Bugged the server.
And then they've been trying to figure out.
What it was but they couldn't.
So that's why they're resetting the server.
So we're still waiting for it.
Bum.
We're just waiting.
Ah I think like.
After the tour.
And we.
I know I said it before.
But after the tour.
And domesticating a dragoon.
We're gonna call it here.
Cause I'm getting a little eepy.
Just getting a little eepy right now.
Yeah.
It's really late.
Um.
I might push the sunland stream.
A bit later.
Uh.
Just cause like.
We're having like fire alarms being checked.
In my apartment.
So like.
I'm gonna see if like.
I'm gonna see if fire alarms will be checked.
Before my stream.
And then if.
If the fire alarm people doesn't come to check it.
Then I might stream.
A little.
I might push the stream back until.
Uh.
Until like.
They check it.
Cause they have to come into my PC room.
I think it's a little awkward.
You know.
It's like the xQc thing.
Where I don't know if you guys have seen the.
One of the infamous xQc clips.
Where uh.
He was you know streaming.
And then the maids came in.
Like his maids came in.
And was just like judging him.
Like I don't wanna be judged.
I don't wanna be.
Judged live.
By the fire alarm people.
Uh.
Oh you guys haven't seen it?
It's like honestly.
Okay here.
Let me see.
Bum bum da da da da.
Happy new year.
Alright xQc.
Uh.
Maids.
It's what inspired.
It's the one that.
Uh inspired the.
Um.
Inspired the.
Uh the meat canyon video.
Yeah.
Oh it's on now.
Okay.
Alright they have to back up the server.
But anyway this is the xQc video.
I was talking about.
And that is like one of the reasons why I'm thinking about starting.
The stream later.
Because I'm scared.
I don't.
I don't wanna be judged.
I'm kidding.
Alright let's see.
xQc has maids.
xQc is a fucking millionaire.
You know like those gambling sponsors he takes.
Like from that alone.
You can get like a million plus.
Like.
Like no shit.
Of course he has maids.
xQc has maids.
Alright.
We're loading in.
He can afford it.
He gets like 50k viewers every stream.
She was reading what he wrote.
I mean yeah.
That's gonna mean like.
What the fire alarm guy is gonna think.
When I start streaming.
Gambling is too lucratif.
It's not even a leak.
It's common knowledge.
Why else would they like.
Fucking take those sponsors.
And like willing to.
Oh my god I'm alive.
You guys thought I would die.
Alright.
I'm back.
Wait I'm naked.
No I was supposed to be naked.
I'm naked.
Okay.
You guys said I would die!
Look at me!
I am alive!
But where is...
Where is Hiro?
Where is my carry?
Oh no.
Oh wait, I have a Parasaur saddle?
How the fuck did I get all these things?
Okay, let me eat though.
I'm like so hungry.
Okay, where is...
Oh, okay, they're still loading in.
We can explore a little bit.
They're apparently...
They're apparently loading in.
Guys...
How do I explore?
Oh guys, you wanna see how strong I am?
Look at this.
That's how strong I am, guys.
88 wood.
Off the bat.
Alright.
Okay, let's like level up some stuff.
Okay, apparently we want movement speed, and then we want stamina, HP, stamina, weight, melee, weight, health.
Okay, there you go.
That should be fine.
So how do I craft?
Oh, see?
They're online.
That's me.
I'm real female doki.
I'm right over here.
Oh, Ditto's...
Oh yeah, Ditto's in here too.
Wait, what the fuck?
Why am I not an admin?
God!
What the fuck?
How come Ditto is an admin and I'm not?
Wait a minute.
Wait, is that mine?
Taming...
Defectiveness... wild.
Wait, what does that mean?
Let's see.
I wonder where did my...
Wait, what is that?
Is this a...
What is this?
What that...
What is that?
Guys, what the fuck is this?
It says...
My taming list, but I don't know.
Wait, I... I knocked down?
Who did... Who the fuck is this?
This is not the dragoon.
Because I never tamed a dragoon.
Oh, someone is taming a creature right now.
Oh, it's not me.
Okay.
Oh, someone in my tribe is taming it.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Okay.
How do they know where I am?
Hello!
Kero!
Nachan!
Hello!
Somebody save me!
Oh, hey, crafting.
Can I craft a gun now?
Craft one.
Do I have a gun?
Where is it?
Oh my god, guys.
What the fuck is this?
Oh, it's a toy!
Oh!
Okay, it looks like a gun.
I'm lost.
Wait, I'm next to...
Next to building...
Next to...
Castle.
I'm in a hole.
Okay, I'm in the hole.
Is that pickaxe?
Hold and reload.
Multi-tool.
But it looks like a gun!
Look at it!
Oh, it's a mod.
Please don't hurt me.
Hello!
Oh god, oh no.
I'm just...
Leave me alone!
Ah!
Help!
There's a bird chasing me!
Oh no.
Are they... they're not friend-shaped?
Keep moving.
Bird vs... Okay, this guy seems nice.
You're hot.
You should find some place to cool down.
I'm literally wearing a bikini.
What the fuck do you want from me?
I have the high ground.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Okay, what does my map say?
I don't know what that means.
80 of 40.
Okay.
Is that...
Look, I even cocked a gun!
I'm sad.
I created something useless.
That seems like something I do.
Oh!
Hello!
Yeah!
It's me!
I'm here!
I was so scared.
I was so scared, Hiro.
A bird tried to kill me.
Yeah, my Hiro!
My Hiro!
I thought you were trying to go here.
Yeah!
Oh, here it is!
Wait, did you guys build this?
No!
Wait, did...
This is the crazy guy!
This is the crazy guy?!
Wait, is he online?
Is he okay?
I don't know.
I think he's loading it.
Wait, if we kill...
We should make a cage on him!
Put a cage around him before he can go crazy.
Oh!
Oh, you have a beautiful home, sir.
You have...
Hello!
Hiro!
Do you speak Cantonese?
I'm Cantonese.
Oh, you're Cantonese?
Yes,
I can understand.
Oh my god!
I can actually understand!
Is he a Hiro?
Are you a crazy person?
He told me.
Am I crazy?
Yes, he said you're a crazy person.
Hahaha!
No, you...
You said I'm crazy.
You're crazy!
He is...
He's crazy!
He's been cheating me so many times.
Hahaha!
You've been cheating me so many times.
He's been cheating you so many times.
Why is there a person in your house?
Why are you catching people?
You have three people.
Why did you catch three people?
You...
What are you doing?
This...
He's better.
Hahaha!
You're so awesome.
He's a...
Hello, hello.
Hello!
Hello, nice to meet you.
Hello, nice to meet you too!
Hahaha!
My English is fine.
Your English is amazing.
It's beautiful.
It is great.
Oh!
Hahaha!
What did you do?
Haha!
I want to take my dressbook.
Hahaha!
She died.
Yes, yes.
Bless me.
Hahaha!
Good luck!
Bless me.
This is Cory.
His name is Cory.
Cory?
Hello hello.
So what are you doing?
You locked the three of us in the box.
It's good looking.
Do you think it's good looking?
It's good looking too.
I'm dead!
I'm dehydrated!
I'm thirsty.
I want to drink something.
Help me.
I'm out of water.
I don't have water.
I'm going to dehydrate.
I'm okay.
Do you guys have water?
Oh my god.
I can't see anything.
Remember to always hydrate.
Wait.
How come I can't see anything now?
I can't see names.
Oh no.
Guys.
I can't see anything on my screen.
What happened?
There's no more water.
Did you hide your UI?
Wait.
My UI is gone.
I don't know what that is.
Oh my god.
I can't see your name.
Oh.
Okay.
Never mind.
It's because I pushed backspace.
I figured it out.
I pressed the wrong button.
Oh yeah.
Do you have water?
Apparently, I fixed it.
Yeah.
I fixed it.
Okay.
I think you have my bottle right?
Yeah.
I have a canteen.
But I don't know where to get water.
There's no water in there already?
Okay.
I'm dehydrated.
Yay!
Wait.
Where's... What's Nachan doing?
Oh wait.
Can you just throw me into the water?
And then I get water from that?
Oh!
Okay.
I drink.
Wait.
What?
Oh my god.
I'm 1 HP.
Pick me up.
And I'm dying.
No!
I'm broken!
Wait.
I'm still alive.
Okay.
And I pooped a little bit.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
My bones are back to normal.
My bones are back.
It's okay.
It just magically healed.
If you got slapped by a prehistoric animal, you too would poop out of fear.
Don't lie.
You'd do it if it was a rhino from modern creatures.
I'm alive!
Oh my god, pick me up!
I'm so s-
When did I die?
No fucking way!
Guys, we're in hell.
Okay.
What the f- Did you bleed?
Bleed it?
It's the huge X.
There's a huge X.
Where the fuck is the X?
What do you mean a huge X?
Everything went- Where are you?
Where- Oh!
There it is!
Wait, I found it!
Guys!
Guys, I found it.
I am at...
I am- What bed am I in?
What the fuck am I?
I'm- Oh wait.
I spawned...
at the...
bide.
Oh my god, wait, is this a dinosaur?
Oh my god, it is!
Wait, is this dinosaur meant to...
for spawning?
What the fuck?
Oh, that was what's being tamed.
Bide?
Oh, I don't know.
It's like...
I don't know what the fuck is that.
Oh, oh, it's a Shrider!
Shrider!
Um...
Tech Shrider.
Strider.
It's blue...
and tall...
and metal.
Oh, tall.
This is it.
This is where- This is where I live.
No, my bikini!
No!
Wait, I have glasses!
Wait, not grindable.
Hello?
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
I just died.
Kiro killed me.
Yeah, he killed me.
Oh my god!
You have...
Oh my god.
I'm being fed by the...
Thank you.
I'm dead.
I'm waiting for Kiro to pick me up.
I don't even know where I am.
I want to hear it.
It's so poetic.
Every time!
Every fucking bug!
Like, are you serious?
Every time I get on a fi- Every time!
Every insect fucked me over.
We're back.
Every insect has fucked me over.
I had one that killed me several times.
And then another one, literally, got on the fucking insect mount.
And then I died.
My PC died.
My aim.
All bugs are against me.
I just want my loot bag.
I want my...
Please, please don't put me in the cage!
Don't put me in the cage!
Please!
I'm scared.
I'm scared I'm gonna be...
They'll be like...
She crashed.
She started to put Doki in the cage.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
Please don't put me in the cage.
I'm scared that he's gonna realize I crashed and then...
And then just locks me up.
It's not looking...
I thought we were friends.
We spoke Cantonese to each other.
Hello?
No!
Oh my god!
Why?
Why did you put me in there?
It's so big.
But I think if I'm here, I won't be able to see.
If I'm here, I won't be able to see.
Oh my god!
She almost put me in the cage.
Hero!
Ew, that's a huge peanut.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she almost put me in the cage!
Oh my god!
That was so scary!
I almost got fucking put in the cage!
Oh my god.
Wait, are these in the cage?!
What?
The peanut had a peanut on it.
It's like a peanut on a peanut!
I was like, I'm going to go to the cage.
Everyone was like, okay.
No, I was like...
That could have been me!
It could have been me!
So cold.
I was like, I'm going to go to the cage.
Oh my god, she almost got me!
Oh my god, I called it!
I fucking called it!
I knew it, guys!
I fucking called it, guys!
I knew she wanted to put me in the cage!
I fucking knew it!
Oh my god, that was so close.
She's the collector.
Holy shit!
What happened last time?
Yeah, I got saved.
Alright.
I got saved.
Dude, I... Huh?
What?
Oh my god!
Are you crazy?
Are you...
Help!
God!
God, get it out of me.
Hey, she's crazy!
I pulled my shirt up!
Hahah all cosa!
She's crazy!
Hahaha!
Okay, hit her!
Hit her!
Save me!
I don't care.
Hahahaha!
Hahahahahaha!
AHHHHHH!!!!
Hahahaha!
Oh my god!
Go Mera!
Go!
No!
Go Mera!
Go on!
I can't sleep!
Go Mera!
Oh my god!
Go on!
Mera!
Hit him!
Save me!
She's crazy!
Help me!
Crazy!
He fucking knocked me out and put me in a cage!
He shot me!
What the fuck?
Hiro!
Let me out, Hiro!
I got it.
I got it so bad.
Hiro, you were right!
Hiro, you were right, Hiro!
Oh, thank you!
Okay.
I thought I would get out of the handcuffs.
Oh my god.
No!
I'm not okay!
He put me in a cage!
Yeah, he's hurting.
I called you.
You were right!
Don't worry.
I put some shit in his... in her home.
He put some shit!
My Hiro.
Wait, where's my... do you know where my...
I put some shit.
Don't worry.
You've got to help me.
Look over here, look over here.
Oh my god.
She has so many people in cages!
Look at this!
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
Do you know where my body is?
Yeah, yeah.
Can you take me... I want my bikini back.
Wait, what do I have?
Oh, I have water, Jai.
Oh my god, she gave me water.
I have a whip now.
Bad!
She gave me a whip.
Can you bring me back to my body?
Yeah, I can.
I'm gonna give you something.
Oh, yes.
I want... what is this?
Oh my god, your blood!
Don't worry, I'll keep it forever.
Okay.
Goodbye, everybody.
Bye-bye.
Alright, I want my stuff back.
I want my bikini back.
The crazy person gave me a whip.
Ha!
Oh, she freaky... I'm not the freaky one!
She gave me a whip!
She gave me the whip!
I can't believe... I fucking knew it.
Yeah, the crazy person gave me the whip.
And then they like locked me in a cage.
She was like... she was like...
Yeah, yeah.
She was like, look at this.
And then she pulled a gun and then knocked me out and then put me in a cage.
It was... it was so scary.
I don't know why it's like that.
Did you die?
Was it here?
I think so.
Was it?
I don't remember.
Oh, wait.
Where did I die?
Wait, I have a map.
Okay, I can't...
I think it's here.
Was it here?
Where?
I don't see like the light.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
It's here.
It's like... wait.
Oh my god, Nachan died!
Yeah, she's dying now.
She's trying to get her...
Okay, I got my stuff back.
Let me put my... let me put my bikini on.
Yay!
Okay, now I'm beautiful.
Alright.
Nice.
Yay!
Where are we going?
Don't call me, Nachan.
I will try and...
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna go to Nachan now.
Actually, yeah, I can try and do something.
Oh, okay.
It's like a new...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, nothing is loading in yet.
It's draining, yeah.
It's draining right now.
You must be... what?
I'm a little...
No, Nachan, no!
Live for me!
Okay.
Oh?
Who's that?
What are you doing?
I'm a little...
I'm not here right now.
Ah,
okay, okay.
You can come back.
Together?
Okay, together.
You can come back with us.
Okay.
She's a family.
Nice.
It's okay.
Yeah, family.
Yes, yes.
Oh my god, it's okay.
As long as she doesn't put me in the cage, I'm fine.
Wait, Nachan died again?
Thank you, Hiro.
I'm sorry.
Oh no.
Nachan's still dead.
Am I pooping in the sky?
Where?
Nachan is dying.
Yeah, she's dying non-stop.
Oh my god.
Oh no!
Nachan, don't worry!
I'll save you!
Nachan!
My inventory's too heavy!
Where is Nachan?
Wait, where is Nachan?
Where is she?
Oh no.
Wait, there she... oh wait, no.
She's not there.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Ah!
He took my... suit.
Wait, I should throw some stuff away.
I have too much stuff.
Yeah, guys, I have too much!
What the fuck?
Okay, we're good.
We have like the same armor.
A lot of the same armor.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, let's see.
Green is... green is the weak one.
Okay, I have a lot of these skins.
I don't think we need like 500.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Okay.
No!
Where is Nachan?
Ah, I saw her.
Nachan!
You're alive!
Oh my god.
Nachan!
What are you?
Hi!
Look, Nachan.
Look what I have.
Look.
That's scary.
That's her.
Okay, what do I not need?
I don't need all of this.
Okay, let me drop all of this.
Oh my god.
I...
Okay, yeah, I have so many like duplicates from dying all the time.
I cannot fit all of this.
Okay, nice.
Nachan, jump.
Yay!
I'm really tired, so like I'm glad...
Well, I'm not glad that I crashed, but like I'm gonna...
I think that's like the... I think it's at that time we gotta stop.
I think Ark just does not like me right now.
So I'm gonna call it here.
It was fun though.
I'm really happy that Hiro and her friends like gave me a tour and everybody's so nice on the server.
I had a great time just talking, like interacting with people.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching too.
I hope all you guys had a great time just watching and being put in a fucking cage.
I'm gonna call it here.
I'm actually really tired now.
I'm gonna...
I do have like some work stuff at the answer.
So I'll let you guys know.
I'm gonna push back the satellite stream right now.
I'm gonna change the time for it.
So... and if like the fire inspector person that's supposed to check the fire alarms doesn't come by then, I might just wait until they check the alarms and then...
And then start the stream.
Okay.
But yeah, it was really fun.
I had a great time.
I'm gonna call it here.
My voice is dying.
I'm a bit... I'm EP now.
But as always everybody stay hydrated, posture checked, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!